¿Qué pasa, Pizarritas? Hoy es viernes y no es un viernes cualquiera porque hoy hemos venido
perfectamente uniformados y bellísimos, esto ya lo digo yo, pero bueno, imagino que vosotros pensaréis lo mismo
con las nuevas equipaciones de Pizarritas, Bay, Gambéa, ¿qué tal Adrián Blanco, Alés de Llano, Nahuel, Miranda, cómo estáis?
¿Qué tal chicos, muy buenas?
¿Qué tal, cómo estamos?
Qué complicado es empezar así.
Sí, la verdad es que los comienzos son siempre difíciles y mira que hay alguno que es particularmente duro.
Bellos, Quintana, bellos estamos siempre, pero hoy en pantalla hay más bello de la habitual.
Es que mira ese bigotito que se asoma por encima de la P de Pizarritas.
Chicos, yo lo siento porque no podéis expresar vuestra hombría simplemente quitándoos la camiseta,
si no tenéis que hacer más cosas, pero los hombres normalmente, los machos, el macho ibérico tiene pelo en el pecho.
No sé cómo de macho eres, pero ibérico eres.
Oye, que refresca un poquito en Madrid, pero eso de ponerte la térmica para grabar el vídeo es como raro.
Bueno, que tenemos...
La chaqueta con borreguito, eh, me he puesto.
Tenemos nuevas equipaciones de Gambéa para Pizarritas, es un primer prototipo,
quizás en el segundo por la salud capilar del pecho de Alex de Llano lo cerramos un poquito,
pero Adri, enséñale los detallitos, porque el escudo está bordado a mano por el señor Gambéa.
Directamente.
Uno a uno, puntada a puntada.
Sí, sí, pero lo mejor es esto.
¡Espera, espera, espera!
Claro, espera, espera, porque a ver, lo que mola de Gambéa y de esta faceta custom que tienen en la tienda
es que ellos te personalizan, pero personalizado de verdad, y te asesoran,
no como a veces algunas marcas que le dan la misma equipación pero con otro color, yo qué sé,
a cinco equipos de las grandes ligas, que son la misma, pero una roja, otra verde y otra blanca, ¿vale?
Aquí no, aquí hay personalización, adaptación, asesoría, un diseñador top,
ahora os explicamos cositas de esto, pero el caso es que a nosotros nos han visto,
sobre todo a uno de nosotros, cara de Adriano, y han dicho, levanta, levanta Adri.
Mira, mira, mira, mira, mira, mira.
¡Eeeeh!
Es espectacular, lo de Pizarritas con la P de Pirelli es espectacular.
Para poder derrapar en las mejores condiciones.
Claro, todo va sobre ruedas en la pizarras de hecho.
A ver, prontito, la historia de éxito, Miguel, es el Panathinauticos,
mejor equipo del Fútbol Siete madrileño, el año pasado vestía muy parecido a su equipo homónimo,
este temporada ha encargado no una, sino dos equipaciones nuevas.
Sí, con Gambea, con la personalización de las camisetas.
Exactamente, es que custom, la verdad es que no, custom, customización, lo hacemos castellano,
con esa asesoría exactamente perfecta para equipos de fútbol, grupos de amigos,
despedidas de soltero o gente con pelo en pecho, como estáis viendo.
Mira, ahora que citas lo de la despedida soltero, vi una idea de despedida soltero que me pareció supergraciosa, que era...
Como cañete.
No, no digas nada, porque igual...
La de Nahuel dices.
No, no, la de...
Ya igual, se van dando pasos ¿no?
Sí, en firme además.
¡Ya tenemos casa!
¡Vamos!
¡Es propietario, Adrián Blanco!
Propietario, propietario por fin.
P de propietario.
P de propietario, efectivamente, va por ello.
P de pelado y P de...
¡De porrero!
He pasado por el aro de la inmobiliaria, lo cual me ha puteado bastante también con P,
porque me he dejado una pasta también con P en la inmobiliaria,
pero sí, sí, ya estamos por eso.
No sale Zetangana últimamente en los vídeos, chicos.
No, no, no vamos a contar cuál es tu nueva profesión para poderla pagar la hipoteca,
pero también empieza por P.
El caso, prontito, prontito, prontito en
gambaesopeninstagram y somospizzarritas.
Vamos a sortear una equipación para vuestro equipo, grupo de amigos,
lo que sea, lo que vosotros queráis.
Prontito en Instagram, próxima semana.
Atentos. Mientras, si es que os podéis concentrar en el fútbol viendo esos pelitos,
vamos con la primera cuestión de Aguilera.
Es que yo no puedo, yo no puedo, yo no puedo, pero voy a intentarlo.
No, mira, mira.
Aguilera79 nos pregunta ¿qué futbolista iguala barra mejora a Julián Álvarez a balón parado?
¿Se os ocurre algún nombre de primeras?
Dilo now.
A ver, el único sería Grimaldo por tema de goles,
pero bueno, es difícil mejorar a Julián, yo creo que la pelea está ahí,
aunque la pregunta puede servir para hablar de grandes lanzadores,
sobre todo ya no tanto en cuanto a las faltas, sino en cuanto a Corners.
Hay uno por cierto que ha jugado poco hasta ahora en la Liga,
pero tiene muy buena pinta que es Ugrinic en Valencia,
que lanza muy bien los Corners,
y de hecho es parte del motivo por el cual lo fichan.
Luego hay una pregunta sobre esto, sobre elegir una pareja de lanzadores rematador,
que podamos dar.
¿De la Liga o de Europa?
De la Liga y de Europa, no sé si haces la pregunta, luego os la planteo.
No tenía una de Asia, fíjate.
Hay una cosa, comentarlo de Grimaldo,
creo que Grimaldo tiene pinta, porque estamos descubriendo a Julián también en esta faceta,
que ya había marcado goles, pero bueno, lo estamos descubriendo aquí en Atlético Madrid.
Grimaldo me parece que tiene más rango y más variedad, es mi sensación,
pero el golpeo de Julián en la frontal, que es un golpeo muy parecido al que luego tienen los Corners,
lo está automatizando, Adri, es que no se le levanta el balón.
Tú no ves un Corner de Julián que no vaya a zona de remate,
y no ves un disparo a balón parado directo de Julián que se vaya al tercer anfiteatro,
luego lo puede parar el portero, puede ir fuera, pero es automático,
se está cogiendo ya esa técnica y la tiene muy depurada.
Sí, el otro día decía Simeone que le recordaba mucho cómo chutaba Julián a cómo chutaba en su día Pantic,
también, que cae muy a plomo la pelota, que cae muy a plomo,
él no sabe cómo conseguir levantarla para que después caiga inmediatamente,
ha hablado después de marcarle el gol a Courtois en el derbi.
Aquí la clave es, falta la minuto 89, ¿quién tira esa falta o quién quiere que tire esa falta?
¿Dónde está?
Hoy por hoy yo sigo diciendo que tire Grimaldo, pero...
Aunque esté en la frontal.
En la retraso un poco.
Y una cosa, Leomé si sigue en activo.
Sí, también es verdad.
Lo digo a ver si vamos a pasar esta pregunta y no mencionamos a Leo.
Dicho esto, ¿se va a seguir encargando Julián del balón parado de la Lety?
Porque vuelve Baena.
Y Baena en los corners, la pone muy bien.
Una pregunta que ya sabéis que tengo problemas con esto, Julián es diestro o zurdo?
Diestro.
Y Baena, diestro.
Esto lo escuché a Tiago el otro día que decía que en general entre los centrocampistas hay demasiado perfil diestro.
Que le hablaba de acomodar el perfil más jugón, ponerlo a pierna cambiada.
Por aquello de meterse mucho hacia adentro y el perfil más box to box que juega a pierna natural.
Sí, bueno de hecho esto hablan, no sé qué entrenador fue, que se habla mucho de no poner a dos centrales zurdos.
Pero menos de no poner a dos centrales zurdos.
Porque el zurdo, ¿por qué se dice esto del zurdo en vez del diestro?
Porque por norma general suele ser más cerrado.
Y claro, eso ya para un central puede ser un problema.
Pero en el centro del campo donde tienes que girar, perfilar y demás, es que anulas una parte del campo.
O sea, piensas en cualquier central y siempre tienes un lado natural y un lado más ciego.
Y esto no es un tema...
Yo creo que la pareja de mejores lanzadores de balón parado, que veremos cómo se asienta la de Baena Julián, la tiene el Arsenal.
Con Reis y Odegaard.
Me gustan mucho los corners de Julián, de verdad.
Si los defienden en el entro de Frankfurt más.
El que saca muy bien los corners con las dos piernas es Cazorla también.
Brutal, eh.
Esto le gana Casillas.
Es verdad.
De hecho creo que es el primer gol que te hace dudar de Casillas.
¿Es en el Bernabéu ese gol?
Creo que sí, lo estoy visualizando.
Golazo de Santi Cazorla.
Segunda cuestión.
Gauchia Pastor.
Dice, visto lo ocurrido en las últimas jornadas de Liga, se empieza a dudar de Carlos Corberán por Twitter.
Dice Gauchia Pastor que le da todo el crédito del mundo.
Pero nos pregunta si pensamos que puede haber cama por parte de los futbolistas.
Aquí, Now Alex, lo hemos venido hablando fuera de micros durante la mañana de hoy.
Para nosotros es miércoles, que estamos hablando hasta el miércoles al mediodía.
Hay run run.
Y lo han conjuntado nuestros compañeros de Radio Marca Valencia.
Con ciertas decisiones de Corberán.
Con ciertas sensaciones del vestuario.
Y creo que es pronto para hablar de desaveniencias, al menos por lo que vamos conociendo.
Pero sí que podemos entrar en el terreno de las tiranteces.
Estoy completamente, sí.
Ha habido cosas raras durante el verano.
Se habló mucho del tema del dorsal de Dan Yuma.
Las dudas con la salida de Guillamón, que no fue tratado de la mejor manera.
El tema de la capitania de Pepelu, que viene de la temporada pasada y todo el jaleo de Rafa Mir.
En fin, daba la sensación de que el año pasado el vestuario consiguió unirse en una situación muy negativa.
Y que esta temporada ya no está en el mismo punto.
Es que Corberán rechaza hablar de la situación de Raba, que venía siendo muy importante.
Y que después de la expulsión de Gaya en el Sadar, hace un mal gesto al vestuario y ha pasado a ser un futbolista totalmente residual.
Y Corberán dice que está todo bien.
Hay dudas sobre todo por eso, pero la gente que mejor conoce el vestuario habla de que la situación está un poquito rara ahí dentro.
Y yo sobre todo creo que se han ido generando esos problemas que comentabais.
Pero es que las declaraciones después del partido del Real Oviedo,
o sea, el momento en que piden analizar los goles y analiza el 1-1 y el 1-2.
Cuidadito eso, eh.
Y empieza a repartir hacia todos los jugadores, porque habla de Santa María, habla de Gaya, habla de todos.
Creo que de Diakaví.
Parece que con Diakaví es una parte de los problemas importantes.
Sí.
Y claro, ahora mismo pues el valencianismo se encuentra de nuevo en mitad en un desastre que puede ser.
El hecho de que el vestuario no termine de aceptar a Carlos Corberán.
Porque ya sería una temporada más en la que el Valencia entra en el bucle.
También entrado.
Esto es lo peor posible, porque el Valencia en verano asume ciertos riesgos en la gestión de grupo.
Esto en su día con Baraja, lo comentamos alguna vez.
Baraja dijo no a algún perfil de jugador interesante,
pero que quizás podía romper un poco la armonía de ese vestuario.
Bueno, el Valencia firma a jugadores particulares.
Dan Juma, Ramazani, Dani Raba son jugadores particulares.
Tú preguntas en Vila Real por Dani Raba y te cuentan que Dani Raba no es de gestión fácil.
Esto quiere decir que se sabía de antes.
Claro, no es algo sobrevinido.
La mitad del loco lo autizamos en agosto, no es de ahora.
Exactamente.
Pero lo curioso y lo sorprendente es que parece que los problemas no son con estos,
sino es con la base de jugadores, no sé si llamarlo valencianistas y demás,
porque hay un poco de todo, pero pues eso, Pepe, Lugallad, Yacabit,
o sea, el núcleo fuerte del vestuario exactamente parece que está por ahí.
Y al final, Adri, decíamos en verano que había dos retos por parte de Valencia.
Uno, tener la misma energía y actividad del año pasado sin un cambio de entrenador,
porque esto siempre airea mucho.
Y luego el tema de si Carlos Corbera iba a poder ir metiendo matices e ir mejorando cosas,
porque esto yo lo decía a juicio particular, creo que el Valencia el año pasado tuvo momentos de sobrepuntuación
por un tema de dinámica.
Esto pasa mucho y no pasa nada.
Eder Sarabia vino a reconocer el otro día en la pizarra que Suelche quizás tiene algún puntito más de lo que dice el juego.
No pasa nada. Esto es fútbol. Luego se equilibra.
Pero claro, a lo que iba, si has perdido a parte del vestuario,
tan pronto ya ni vas a mantener esa energía, actividad, concentración que tuviste,
ni te van a seguir ni a creer para introducir las novedades y matices que quieras en este segundo año.
Es una situación que si no mejora, cuidado.
Cuidado, cuidado.
Es verdad que por lo que comentaban nuestros cómpis de Radio Marca Valencia,
no está todavía en el extremo de ser lo que ha pasado en Mallorca.
No es que haya una guerra civil dentro todavía, no hemos llegado a ese punto,
pero sí hay que tener cuidado.
Hay que tener cuidado porque esto puede terminar explotando y salirle muy mal al Valencia.
Corberán sabrá.
A mí Dan Juma me parece un jugadorazo.
Pero yo no me iría a la guerra con Dan Juma, sinceramente.
Dan Juma conviento de que está muy bien.
Lo del dorsal creo…
El dos de octubre ya Diego López.
Claro.
Sin estar dentro hay muchas cosas que no se pueden juzgar.
Pero desde fuera, si hay un jugador de la cantera que renueva…
La cantera, es verdad que pasa por varias canteras,
pero viene del fútbol formativo de Paterna.
Como Diego López, que es parte del proyecto y te pide un número,
y se lo dan a un tío que viene nuevo.
De aquella manera…
Es un chaleo.
Sí, que está más asentado en esa plantilla.
Esto en su día ya pasó, por cierto, con Carlos Soler y con Kangin.
La propiedad que era de Kangin ni fuera el 10 del Valencia.
Kangin tiene una personalidad diferente dentro del vestuario.
Al final se optó porque ninguno de los dos.
La propiedad no quería que fuera Soler y el vestuario no quería que fuera Kangin.
¿Y quién fue?
Almeida.
Quedó vacante.
Que era el Valencia de todas las ventas.
Sobraron fichas ese verano en el Valencia de Javi Gracia.
Era para Capú.
Perdón.
Esto es de Celades, creo.
Pero bueno, el caso.
Sí que es cierto que en todo esto hay un elemento que quedó muy raro.
Hay un penalti.
Está Pepe Lul sobre el terreno de juego y lo tira Dan Yuma.
Dan Yuma después del partido dijo que lo falla.
Que fue Pepe Lul que fue a preguntarle si quería lanzarlo él.
Esto es lo único que dice Soler.
Lo rescatamos dentro de toda esa serie de malos indicios que descenden el Valencia.
Cosita rara de esto de no me gusta como caza la perrita.
Es que hay tanta igualdad, lo decimos siempre en verano.
A partir del octavo noveno hay tanta igualdad respecto al viejísimo.
Que los clubes que no van a una normalmente son los que van al Rinchi.
Esto es así y lo estamos viendo en Mallorca, lo vimos en Pucela.
Tercera cuestión.
Gavino Gómez Sánchez.
Una cuestión muy repetida.
En las preguntas de Twitter.
Cada vez me pregunta dónde dejar las preguntas.
En Twitter.
Depende de la semana y cuando grabemos.
En Instagram de Nahuel Miranda también.
Sí, ahí son muy bien acogidas.
Las que no crees que salgan...
Ahí está el buzón.
No me pede la turra por Instagram.
Es que hay una cosa muy graciosa.
Os queremos mucho, ¿vale? Pizarritas.
Pero hay veces rollo.
¿A qué hora juega el Athletic Club la próxima semana?
¿A quién pongo en el fantasy?
A nadie.
La pregunta del fantasy la puedo entender.
Hay gente...
Se la haces a Don Quijote de la cancha.
Claro.
Pero hay preguntas rollo Pizarritas GPT.
Que tienes Google, cabrón.
Bueno.
¿Qué te parece el fichaje de este uruguayo por el Ceuta?
¡Me la pela!
Oye, Pizarritas GPT molaría.
Sí.
Yo lo puedo crear.
Voy a crear.
Con pelo en pecho para que no os cabréis.
¿Cómo veis el encaje o la compatibilidad
entre lo que es Jude Bellingham
y lo que es Arda Uhler
y el Madrid Necesita de ambos?
Se está hablando de Fede,
pero esto me parece más relevante.
Y ojo, ahora dais la respuesta,
pero debo decir que estoy totalmente de acuerdo
con lo que dice Gavino,
porque tú tienes que establecer prioridades
y creo que la prioridad debe ser la que más te gusta.
Y creo que la prioridad debe ser encajar a Bellingham
con Vinicius Yemba P.
Y encajar el Bellingham-Uhler.
A partir de ahí, decides sobre Fede.
No decides primero sobre Fede.
Y luego sobre Bellingham y Uhler.
Creo que esto igual al uruguayo
le sienta mal, lo puedo llegar a entender,
lleva mucho tiempo, es importante.
Pero creo que la importancia de Fede Valverde
está precisamente en eso.
En ser un equilibrador y un compensador
de los diferentes Real Madrid
en los que ha jugado y jugará.
Pero ahora mismo el tema es
a quién le doy la base, a quién le doy la media punta
y cómo se compenetran con Yemba P. Vinicius.
Y teniendo en cuenta
que Uhler está mezclando muy bien con Yemba P.
Esto también tiene que tenerlo presente,
sabe Alonso, a la hora de darle forma al sistema.
Yo creo que acabaremos viendo
a Chouamé Ni como medio centro
y dos interiores por delante,
que serán Bellingham y Uhler.
Y que los dos se repartan ese primer espacio
y la media punta.
Que hay que tenerlo en cuenta.
Que haya bastante fluidez entre ambos
para alternarse esos dos escalones
y que Seylor y Alonso se configuran.
Y Valverde, banda derecha.
Eso es, y Valverde por la derecha.
Es donde más le podría dar a Madrid.
Teniendo en cuenta de cómo va a jugar
este Real Madrid.
Teniendo en cuenta que Al-Daguler va a tenerse
protagonismo sobre todo en último tercio.
Que Bellingham puede ser muy relevante
tanto cargando el área como
intentando ser ese hombre
que en conducción al Madrid le pueda plantar
en campo rival. Aunque es verdad que el día
del Atlético de Madrid estuvo súper impreciso.
No le dio giro al equipo.
No fue capaz de imponerse.
Pero sobre todo, yo creo que Fede Valverde
con ese motor que tiene, con esa ida y vuelta
ante ausencias tan reseñables como la de Carvajal,
como Trent, que no llega a ser eso.
Me parece que partiendo desde la derecha
en un sistema en el que no tenga que defender tanto
le podría dar muchísimo a la mano.
A mí, no se me olvida
que el año pasado el mejor amigo
de Mbappé, o la mejor conexión
fue Bellingham también.
Quiero decir...
Sabiá Alonso con Bellingham.
Entonces eso es un dificulte.
Claro, pero yo creo...
Yo veo en Guller
un organizador, un creador y en Bellingham
no. Bellingham creo que es un continuador,
un acelerador, un fodista que abarca mucho campo
que tiene llegada. Creo que
Guller en la media punta
tiene un último pase que Bellingham
no, pero Bellingham tiene una forma de cargar
el área que Guller no, aunque también la carga
porque tiene esa capacidad. Marcó el gol así al Atlético de Madrid.
Yo soy más de poner a Guller por detrás
y a Bellingham por delante.
De hecho es que creo que, lo he dicho hoy en la pizarra,
creo que en unos años veremos
este debate como absurdo.
Porque creo que solo se le da a la media punta
o muchas opiniones
se le da la media punta a Guller por edad
o por ligereza física.
Pero es que esto mismo se decía de Modric
y se decía de Xavi y se decía de muchos
futbolistas que han acabado jugando ahí.
Entonces yo creo que
yo me creo más al Guller organizador
y al Bellingham llegador que viceversa.
Y te digo más,
ahora que no van a estar
en las próximas semanas de competición
ni Carvajal ni Arnold,
mandar a Valverde a la banda
no significa cargarte a Mastantuno.
Creo que pueden entrar todos. Que Cedro Valverde
puede jugar más abierto, que sea el lateral
en defensa y que Mastantuno siga ocupando
el rol que viene ocupando.
¿Sabes lo que pensé con las lesiones de
Carvajal y Trent y todo esto?
Se me ocurrió
el otro día estuvimos haciendo el video
de los esquemas híbridos y el posicionamiento
en ataque. Os lo recomendamos Pizarrita, la verdad es que
estamos bastante contentos con el contenido
y con la acogida.
Se me ocurrió un poco el modelo,
una mezcla de modelo España barra Guardiola.
Imaginaos.
A ver. Courtois en portería.
Lo ponemos ahora en pantalla para que quede claro.
Vamos a decir Militao
Haussen de centrales.
Los laterales en defensa son
Carreras y Fede Valverde
que escoltan al medio centro.
Es decir, dos centrales
Chouaménis, Carreras
a la izquierda, Fede a la derecha
una doble media punta
barra interiores, que son
Bellingham
y Ardaghuller
abierto en izquierda Vinicius
abierto en derecha Mastantuno
y en punta Mbappé.
¿Por qué digo que es algo parecido a una mezcla
de España y City?
Porque España coloca los laterales bajos
para cubrir a Nico Yalamín, que sería un poquito esto
pero sobre todo porque el City
a los pensadores
los ponía por delante.
Kevin de Bruyne y Bernardo o Gondogan
jugaban por delante de
Rodri y John Stones.
Entonces es verdad que Chouamén y no es Rodri
y por ahí igual están un poquito las dudas
pero sería una organización
posicional que, por un lado, convence
a Fede de que puede ser lateral y al mismo tiempo
sacas lo mejor de Guller y Bellingham
pudiendo combinar alturas
como decía Adri
y te permites poner a Mastantuno abierto en banda
que creo que a nivel de presión
y de amplitud de campo te puede dar cositas.
Fue lo que se me ocurrió el otro día.
Creo que me convence más que sea Álvaro Carreras
el tercer central directamente
en ese perfil izquierdo y Valverde a la banda
arriba y lo engañas
de que no estás siendo lateral
estás actuando de extremo, que estás pinchado
en banda para actuar de extremo. Está muy arriba, está más cerca
Fórmulas a Emil.
Yo entiendo a los futbolistas
que quieren una cosa u otra
pero entendía poquito a Cundé
cuando lo comentaba
entiendo poquito a Fede cuando lo dice
o sea, entiendo la respuesta. Ya lo dije el otro día
me parece una respuesta, el titular es potente
la explicación es coherente para mí, bajo mi punto de vista
pero tampoco entiendo mucho si luego
son mil cosas
si Cundé es un lateral bajo que va a hacer un tercer central
Fede puede ser un extremo que se mete por dentro
no sé. Llorente
es todo, es central en salida
central casi lateral
en defensa y extremo en ataque
y más ahora con Xavi Alonso
con Ancelotti es posible que Ancelotti
te pusiese de lateral y subieses
y bajases la banda para centrar, pero con Xavi Alonso
igual te da alguna serie de licencials
que te permiten crecer un poco más
ahora la respuesta
yo cuando vi la respuesta se me vino a la cabeza
el meme este del
sombrero seleccionador
de Harry Potter, al Getafe
ojalá
Raúl Santos, cero 16
creéis que
en el junior
la doble N
le va a quitar el quirúrgico femenina
o a Mario Machín
o a Juan Iglesias
creéis que para un equipo
en mala dinámica como el Rayo, jugar confidence
le puede venir bien para ganar confianza y recuperar efectivos
para la liga y al Celta
con un calendario europeo más complicado
que os parece esto? porque creo que fue
el que dijo que tenía ganas del rock and roll
de los dos partidos por semana
la exigencia para el Celta es bastante superior
a la exigencia para el Rayo
el número de partidos y rivales
lo ha dicho Inigo también
igual me equivoco con Claudio
Inigo decía que
la competición europea
era un generador de buenas dinámicas
que si ganas el jueves, que luego el domingo vas a llegar más contento
al partido
y estáis de acuerdo?
creéis que esto puede ser así?
yo creo que si estás en una mala dinámica
ya puedes ganar
en competición europea
que hay equipos que han terminado
sufriendo o descendiendo
pese a que en Europa podían mantener una buena dinámica
en fases de grupos
medianamente sencillas
a mi me parece que las dinámicas
una victoria en
Moscú no te la cambia
una victoria en... bueno, en Moscú no claro
pero una victoria en...
en Tel Aviv
ha dicho justo
el único sitio donde no
no sabéis porque lo he dicho
porque
yo me acuerdo de la temporada
en la que juegan
Getafe, Ajax
aquella temporada estaban Getafe
y español y Sevilla
si no recuerdo mal eran los representantes
españoles en la Europa League
el español tuvo una fase de grupos
si no recuerdo mal era Feren Varos
Ludo Goretz
y CSKA
y claro, el español
estaba último en Liga
no ganaba ningún partido
y pasó primero de grupo
su fase de grupos de la Europa League
por eso digo que...
pero por ejemplo el Sevilla de Mendy Libar
a raíz de aquel partido de Ultrafor
consiguió espabilar un poquito en Liga también
pero Nao también es verdad
que la plantilla de Sevilla
claro, la plantilla de Sevilla
y en ese invierno llegan
Pup Gay, Brian Hill y me falta otro
llega un tercero
y es una plantilla Champions
con sus errores y sus aciertos
vale, vale
claro, joder, Brian Hill va de Pup Gay
cuidado
el tema es que
hemos destacado tanto del Rayo como del Feta
que tienen plantillas largas
que no hay grandes diferencias
más allá de frutos
por ejemplo el Rayo me parece muy difícil de sustituir
o Legend
por ejemplo
pero que oye, que no hay demasiado
salto de nivel de titular ese suplente
yo al Feta atrás no la veo tan larga
la plantilla
a ver, es que...
no, no, no
por un lado
entra, entra Nao
una obviedad
pero segundo, una cosa con la plantilla larga
de Celta
sí
pero los fichajes
yo elogio
el verano de Marco Garcés
porque estoy de acuerdo a lo que dice
Monchi de no hay malos fichajes
hay malos rendimientos
a mi Brian Zarboza me parecía un fichajazo
Ferran Ljublal me parecía un fichajazo
Mantuviste a Borja Elesias y a Elias Moriva
que por cierto Borja es el mejor
pero Brian Zarboza y Ferran Ljublal
me cago en la leche
se están quedando cortos
y el Celta
que no tiene la alegría con pelota
que quizás es en lo que estará trabajando Claudio
no tiene la alegría con la pelota
el año pasado, si pilla el balón
Brian Zarboza
el otro día el partido
fue insípido
que sea un atajo
necesitan que sean atajos
Adri, porque si Brian Zarboza
no es un atajo, Brian Zarboza te debilita el modelo
porque Brian Zarboza no te presiona
porque Brian Zarboza no es tan responsable
a nivel táctico
yo no estoy de acuerdo con lo que dijo Ancelotti
de hay jugadores que corren
y hay jugadores que marcan la diferencia
porque en el fútbol actual eso es muy difícil
hacer esa división, pero sí que es verdad
que hay jugadores que te refuerzan el modelo
y jugadores que te representan
atajos para el modelo
y creo que Brian es de los segundos
si no es un atajo real
el modelo se te va evaporando
hay que pedirle más a Brian
es evidente que hay que pedirle más a Brian
volver a la pregunta, a mi sí me parece positivo Europa
yo creo que sí es positivo
tener competición europea
siempre y cuando tengas una plantilla
como decía Nau, que estoy también de acuerdo con él
adecuada para ello, para poder compaginarla
donde
cuando no me parece positiva es si te empieza a despistar
volvo a remarcar lo que remarcábamos
antes en tiempo de pizarra
Marcelino está muy pesado diciendo que cuidado con la Champions
que cuidado con la Champions
es una ilusión, que es muy bonita
que todo el mundo la quiere jugar
que nadie se despiste de la Liga
que no le pase como le pasó a Girona la temporada pasada
yo creo que la primera vez que empieza con este discurso
es precisamente la prioridad del Girona
hay otros equipos
que se creen que la vida
es jugar la Champions y la vida es
el día a día en la Liga
mola porque lo dijo Marcelino
como bueno hay ciertos equipos
con entrenadores madrileños
que ficharon a futbolistas
que querían jugar la Champions y cuando la Champions se fue
se la fumaron
fue un poquito eso
no es el caso del Celta
no debería
ni del rayo
seguro fue una licencia para firmar a Juggla
y para firmar a Brian Zaragoza
pero vaya
Juggla creo que es un jugador
que debe asentarse en Vigo
y Brian Zaragoza es un jugador
que debe asentarse en general
a lo que puedo decir es que la plantilla es
prácticamente la misma que el año pasado
el 85 90%
seguramente esta sea
la asignatura
suspensa del gran suspenso de Miche la temporada pasada
acordaos cuando da aquella entrevista
a principio de temporada en la cadena Ser
diciendo que quería que los partidos de Champions durasen
24 horas, que nadie se despistase
que los iba a analizar muy rápido
para que nadie se saliese de la línea
porque creo que es un suspenso
compartido también con la dirección deportiva
hubo futbolistas, esto nos lo contó Jangel Herrera
volvemos a hablar desde la información
directa de una de las fuentes
Jangel nos contó en la pizarra
que había futbolistas muy emocionados
e ilusionados con la Copa de Europa
y cuando la Champions dejó de ser
una motivación o parte del día a día
pues no ya los partidos
sino en los entrenamientos
tened en cuenta que estamos
teniendo este discurso después de que
tanto Celta como Rayo Vallecano
hayan ganado sus repetidos partidos frente a Pau
es que es una promo en redes sociales
del partido donde el estadio de
Vallecas parece
el nuevo estadio metropolitano
parece un estadio
muy bien
los 5 euros que se ahorran los
abonados para ver al Rayo
siempre la directiva
y Martín Presa con el aficionado de Vallecas
oye una cosita solo para finalizar
decir que Rayo y Celta
están jugando mejor de lo que dicen los resultados
creo que pongo por delante
entiendo que los analizamos en par
lo comentamos otro día en las notas
pero Celta pudo ganar
Villarreal, Betis, Mallorca
uno de esos 3 partidos los puede ganar
1 perfectamente igual el año pasado hubiese ganado 2
y el Rayo
del metropolitano pudo sacar algo
al Sevilla mereció ganarlo, al Barça
creo que pudo ganarlo
ganarle
ganarle perdón
que digo ganarlo
soy laista y loista
realmente el problema de origen es
no diferenciar el complemento
directo del indirecto
entonces
ganar a alguien cuando es a quien
es ganarle
si es plural
no me gusta hacer diferencias
no está mal dicho no
ganarlo está mal dicho
de donde nos hablas Alex
que pasa con el micro Alex la estas liando
no no no
si la has estado liando se te ha quedado el micro
no
mejor
se me estaba quedando el ordenador sin batería
y has decidido darle la batería del micro
estamos bien Alex
y has decidido meterte en el cuarto de baño
esta sufriendo Alex
podemos empezar a grabar de nuevo eh Alex
que no
tengo lío
no vamos a decir que lío tengo pero tengo lío
no se le escucha
no no la vida a veces
Alex arregla el micro
realmente no estamos tan mal así
eh
no se me oye
no se me oye no
bueno
mejor así
eh yo avanzo
Alex no se te escucha
Mateo Bimatico
escandel selección
es el portero más decisivo de lo que va
de liga pesadilla con pedir a gente
es que que pesadilla
otro portero más
a tope con Aaron escandel
de verdad está jugando muy bien
que no hay que pedir a la gente para ser el portero
es curioso no que somos un país de clubes
claramente
y queremos que todos los jugadores de nuestros equipos jueguen la selección
y luego cuando van a la selección
que si se accionan
que si juega mucho y no llega
descansado
es el perro del hortelano
escandel es un óptimo jugador que hace dos días
va hasta allá
es el portero de lo que va de liga
yo creo que sí
afirma con la cabeza si estás de acuerdo Alex
bien
ahora bien
si Joan García no fue el año pasado
con una temporada
más completa
más redonda
más top porque estaba Remiro
ahora está Joan García lesionado
Remiro todavía tuvo problemas físicos pero me parece que está bien
me parece muy complicado
y estuvo muy bien con el Albarza
y eso es hizo un partidazo
hay que tener en cuenta que
había gente que decía Remiro selección
pues Remiro solo tuvo que ganar 2-3 años
porque es complicado entrar
sobre todo en un puesto
en el que es residual
esa es la realidad
2-3 años en una real sociedad
que acaba metiéndose en Champions y competiendo muy bien en la Champions
que claro
esto también pasó con Alvaro Valles
en su día con Héctor Fernández
es una cosa que no lo veamos para selección
y otra cosa es que si Narón escandel
igual Adri
tú y yo ya hubiésemos ganado la apuesta
de primer entrenador destituido
creo que si el escandel
Pavonovich
o estaba afuera o tenía las horas contadas
le debo de una cena
claramente a su portero porque si está siendo
el mal decisivo viene a hacer otro gran partido
entre semana ahora ante el Valencia
y es que está
manteniendo con vida al dobierta
que está dando más tiempo en los partidos
y puntos en la clasificación
Alex, este cuanei no lo vas a cobrar
es como ver a Mr Bean
claro
entre el pelo en el pecho
la cara que se está poniendo roja
antes de entrar al cuanei
ha empezado a comer
salmón con boniato
de forma muy desagradable
aprovecha para comértelo Alex
claro
no lo sabes cabrones que lo estoy pasando muy mal
te escuchamos ahora
si claro
pero porque me escucháis por la webcam
porque el micro
a ver, os lo voy a contar
el micro
el receptor se conecta
por el mismo tipo de conexión
que el cargador del ordenador
entonces, ¿qué ocurre?
que es, lo voy a sacar
porque claro no está haciendo nada
es así
entonces ¿qué ocurre?
entonces este magnífico ordenador
fuso los dos cables
los dos agujeros de esto
ah, y no entra en claro
juntos, juntos
con ese vocabulario tan técnico
no termino de entenderlo Alex
no, la verdad es que
entonces claro, yo tengo un adaptador
para estas cosas ¿vale?
¿qué ocurre?
el adaptador
yo creo que está un poco flamenco
porque no me pilla el micro
Alex
quédate así
si
te hemos comprado así
además Adri y yo
ya sabíamos que esto era así
cuando fichas a Dayuma
ya sabes a lo que te expones
claro
pero chicos yo me esfuerzo por hacer las cosas bien
pero con quién te sientes más identificado
con Dayuma, con Ramazan y con Raba
es que el ejemplo de aventura
hoy llevo intentando hacer las cosas bien
toda la mañana, tío
y digo, voy a llegar a casa pronto
como tenemos grabación
antes que nunca, a las dos
que tardo yo una hora en llegar a casa desde la radio
digo, voy a coger la comida de
Mercadona, como
justo cuando me siente para que Miguel
me pueda ir probando y no retrasar
la grabación
y dentro de esto
ayer dejé los micros cargando para tener batería
eres
eres el mejor
siendo el peor
y te queremos así, no cambiar nunca
6ª cuestión
Martín Mac
por qué creéis que el club atlético
de Sazouna de Lizy
la otra vez tuve una buena discusión
si tu dices el club atlético Sazouna
tienes que poner el él
no es como él o Sazouna
Sazouna es la salud y ya lleva
la A, que es el determinante
no estás para dar clases de gramática
si, si estoy
a ese estoy
bueno, que por qué creéis que el club atlético
de Sazouna de Lizy
se cae de esa manera
en las segundas partes
porque es club atlético Sazouna
voy a leer de nuevo la pregunta
que no está quedando clara
por qué creéis que el club atlético Sazouna de Lizy
se...
por qué creéis que
el club atlético Sazouna de Lizy
de esa manera en las segundas partes
a excepción del partido contra el Betis
también va la primera parte
Sazouna sería equipo de Champions contando únicamente
los primeros 45 minutos
es un tema interesante
a mi, debo decir, ya lo he comentado
que no me comenzo Sazouna demasiado en general
ni primeras ni segundas partes
pero creo que el hecho de la
indefinición es
un poco lo mollar
porque cuando el rival da un paso adelante
Alex, Sazouna
no sabe cómo presionar
dónde presionar, dónde hacerse fuerte
es como cuando el rival le hace la pregunta
o Sazouna no tiene clara
la respuesta
si, y además estamos viendo
un equipo que precisamente en términos de continuidad
en términos de
ponerle las cosas muy difíciles
al rival, ha tenido partido
más bien momentos en los que
sí que ha conseguido tenerlo
pero claro chicos, si eres capaz de rendir
muy bien las primeras partes, muy mal las segundas
los partidos duran 90
a mi sinceramente este club atlético Sazouna
no me está transmitiendo nada
o sea, no sé en qué es bueno
el equipo de Lixi
sé que tiene posibilidades para correr con Víctor Buñoz
sé que puede generar peligro
a raíz de las incorporaciones de los
carrileros, que tampoco estamos viendo
una actuación más
desde el parón, yo te diría que lo de
Rozier por ejemplo se ha quedado un poco mal
no, sabes que tiene
buenos futbolistas, porque tú ves a los futbolistas
y dices, es que Sazouna podría estar
yo creo que los pronósticos
Nahoul lo ha metido en Europa League, no, en Champions?
yo lo he metido en Conference
a mi no me parece una locura
lo metí quinto
luego corrigiendo es cierto
que reculeó un poco
analizaremos que es más grave
Girona en Conference u Sazouna en Champions
veremos lo que dice el Ternopu
Miguel, la pelotita
la Gironeta
estamos creciendo
no hay equipo que dé más vergüenza
en la primera edición española que el Girona
estamos creciendo
no, futbol club
sabes como se le llama
los del Girona, no?
Tussuz
son tozudos
son estos Tussuz
por?
lo llevan en camisetas
con el ascenso y tal
es un eslogan de club
no sé si a nivel tradicional también se llevaba
no sé por dónde creéis que va a tirar Lixi
porque teníamos muchas ganas de verle
y yo la sensación es que no le estamos viendo
vamos a intentar
no fijarnos en el nombre
si viene un tío que no conocemos
de la Liga Brasileña
y hace lo que está haciendo Lixi
estaría instituido ya
no hombre
pero es hombre
es un hombre que no se va a ver
y no se va a ver
no hombre
pero no sé
creo que le estamos dando
mucho tiempo y margen
que no se le dio a Vicente Moreno
porque creemos que
Lixi es mejor que Vicente Moreno
pero ves los equipos y no
y el inicio de Lixi
lo hace Almeida, Almeida estaba fuera
no sé, no sé
ha sumado puntos, 17
pero qué decir
le está costando mucho fuera de casa
pero oye que en casa está
convirtiendo bien, que es algo que ya venía de la temporada pasada
la plantilla es prácticamente la misma
calma, cambiaba a Víctor Muñoz
por el rey de Zaragoza
y muy poquito más
hoy juega contra el Getafe
el Getafe sí
yo creo que sí se está viendo la mano de Lixi
por ejemplo en el sistema
este sistema híbrido que lo analizamos
ahí se ve claramente que ha metido ya mano
y que al menos ya lo ves
ves sobre el campo cómo se organizan
compro lo que decíais
que cuando el rival
le cambia un poco las preguntas que Lixi tiene
preparadas antes del partido
le está costando reaccionar
y luego diría que es que más allá de Víctor Muñoz
hay poquitos futbolistas que estén rindiendo
a un gran nivel en este arranque
venimos de un partido donde fíjate la traca que le han
bollo muy catena con la pelota de los pies
ante el Betis
Budi Mirkel lleva un gol
en este arranque de liga
pero lo que pasa Adri
cuando todos los futbolistas están por debajo
ya
séptima posición
es que Osasuna lleva 5 goles
es que está jugando
de verdad es que creo que está jugando muy poquito
Osasuna tiene presunción de inocencia
porque es un buen proyecto
tiene buenos futbolistas
pero luego tú lo ves jugar y quitas
la camiseta, quitas
lo que conoces ya y lo analizas
asépticamente
ganas al Valencia
Valencia se pega un tiro
oye yo creo
el partido del Bernabéu fue bastante mal a pesar del 1-0
creo que
contra el español merece puntuar
contra el Villarreal
estuvo bastante metida en partido
y contra el Rayo
es un partido igualadísimo
igualados
el Rayo no hizo nada
o sea, el Rayo no hizo nada tampoco
y es cierto que el otro día el partido del Betis
es muy malo
pero vamos, yo no veo motivos
para ser el agarmista más allá
de que le está costando despegar
porque no ha sobrado de talento arriba
el equipo, hoy es partido clave
claro tiene un calendario
ese partido del Getafe que estábamos mencionando
al ético de Madrid, Celta
y luego ya es Oviedo, Sevilla
y termina noviembre ante Real Sociedad
y Mallorca
es el partido del famoso gol de Areso
que quiso centrar
si, si, si
hoy lo estaremos comentando
equipo pizarra, Frank Guillén en la narración
casquero y servidor
y el Getafe en esto es prueba del algodón
al Getafe le están faltando muchas cosas
sobre todo en ataque y sobre todo en casa
pero fuera de casa es prueba del algodón
a ver como compite Osasuna
y como quiere jugar el conjunto de Lixi
Donovlak dice
viendo el rendimiento de Llorente
y con la lesión de Dani Carvajal
y también con el cierto de Minguez y Porro
que yo lo de Porro no lo compro tanto
creo que está mucho mejor en el Tottenham que en la selección
pero creo que en el Tottenham
Porro se está mereciendo cada convocatoria que tiene
pregunta, creéis que será el momento
de Marcos en la selección o hay que perder la fe?
yo empezaba a perderla
con ver a Marcos Llorente en la selección
y creo que él mismo también
se ve fuera de la dinámica
de la selección española
al otro día le preguntaban en la pérdida del partido
y le preguntaron por la selección
y vino a decir algo así como
que no le preocupa, que no piensa
en la selección, como no sé
le noté como que hablaba de la selección
como un ente muy lejano, como si no fuese con él
la cosa, yo creo que ha habido momentos
donde estaba para ir, además
del presente ha tenido grandes momentos
donde podía ir y no lo han llevado
así que yo creo que
por muy bien que lo haga
va a ser difícil verlo con la selección
si se abre el casting
y lo que no ha venado, que lo dijo en su día
a mi lo de Eric García
visto lo visto, me empieza a convencer
lo que no compro ahora mismo
es Mingueza porque en la selección
ha flojeado y con el Z está teniendo
un inicio de liga flojo
flojo y sobre todo yo creo que
el tema de Eric te viene muy bien
por esto que estábamos comentando
el lateral bajo para intentar cubrir
mejor a la Min
es una situación de juego
que no le va a ser extraña
y por eso que Eric García que ya ha jugado en esa posición
y más con la Min
de hecho para mi es una
este tipo de situaciones
de ir sumando relaciones
dentro de jugadores nuevos
por ejemplo en el caso de Nico Williams
que yo entiendo que no irá
a esta última convocatoria
me parecería irresponsable
por parte de Luis de la Fuente
a mi me parecería responsable
el jugador selecciona el último parón de selecciones
que está disponible
y las federaciones lo hacen
también tendrían que actuar con responsabilidad
estoy de acuerdo
para que la federación
permite lo que dice Luis de la Fuente
es que para entrenar
en su club que entrené con la selección
otra vez jugar
yo también lo puedo entender en año de mundial
lo puedo entender
otra cosa es que yo puedo jugar
180 minutos
que yo digo que mi candidato número 1
sería Barrenechea
y Mikel Oyarzabal se entienden
con muy poco
es un futbolista que necesita
algo de pulir porque no lo ha llevado nunca
ha sido titular en todas las
categorías inferiores de la selección española
y ahora tiene una oportunidad
hoy es la sorpresa de la convocatoria
que igual cuando estéis viendo este vídeo
ya ha salido
yo me vuelvo que vamos a ver
el Eric Barrenechea
porque también si ya no ha utilizado
yorrente
este nivel
es que para mi no está mejor ahora
que hace 5 meses
y si no lo lleva
sabes
Barrenechea selección
y es un jugador
que me gusta
hombre a ver
yo creo que está mejor
que cuando fue Brian Hill
en la UL
Brian Zaragoza
lo de Brian Hill
hay que entenderlo en clave
que quiere ser el preferente regateador
y por eso también se llevó tan pronto a Brian Zaragoza
pero un poco Barrenechea
no es tan regateador pero es pico de área y eso
no sé
hay que parecer
a Barrenechea la verdad
no soy muy partidario
veo otros futbolistas
que me llevaban mucho antes que Barrenechea
os voy a dar un dato
cuidado
la pareja
es el que no juega de lateral
el alfarero de qué
nos dijeron
en los comentarios lo pusieron
de bloster
ese soy yo
si
pede poste
bueno
el dato y ya seguimos
el futbolista
el futbolista que más ocasiones ha generado
para otro de toda la liga
es Barrenechea a Mikel Bertha
me gusta esa combinación
y estoy de acuerdo con la senta
Erd Hammond
hablando de generar ocasiones
Olise está muy infravalorado a día de hoy
es una broma que queda el número 30
en la lista del balón de oro
que opináis vosotros
yo estoy de acuerdo en que no hubo 29 futbolistas mejores
que Olise
ya explicamos que la lista del balón de oro
funciona como funciona
que tú no lo estás ordenando
y que lo que votan los futbolistas son 10
meter a Olise en el top 10
también es un porro
entonces al final se diluyen muchos puntos
creo que tenía 3 puntos
por eso te digo
pero sí que creo
que yo tenía muchas ganas de ver si de verdad
iba a dar el nivel o incluso a subirlo
del palas en el Bayern
y yo estaba súper optimista
no, escandaloso
el Bayern cae en cuartos
de finales del Champions año pasado
sin pena ni gloria
tiene que pasar por la ronda intermedia
el balón de oro hay que entenderlo
en esa clave
que Olise ha sido de lo más destacado del Bayern
pero el Bayern ha hecho una temporada
muy anodina
para ser el Bayern
te pones a votar y votas a Harry Kane
no votas a Olise
Olise ha empezado la temporada como un cañón
me permitís una cosa
yo soy más de Palmer
que de Olise
pero Olise el año pasado hace mejor temporada
y me diréis si, pero Palmer el mundial de clubes
y la conferencia ya
y Olise cuartos de Champions y Bundesliga
pero bueno entiendo que
es que a mi el Palmer en el top 10
pues que el Palmer sí que gana el título europeo
casi lo meten
la Bundesliga es un título europeo
es que no te podría llamar el microamiguero
voy con él
no me quiera silenciar
soy la buena generación
porque descojonarte a Alex De Llanos no está feo
el del pelo en el pecho
el del micro que no funciona
el de Dalí
el de Pipócrita
Alex tiene muchos amigos
y el de Aleix
el de Aleix
Aleix tiene muchas virtudes
y una es que es un magnífico puchinbol
porque además es que
si no me tiraría por una ventana
aquí no hay ningún hater de Alex De Llanos
hay un hater de Alex De Llanos
el resto somos rovers
verdad o no
porque yo soy muy autocrítico conmigo
equivocadamente como todos tus juicios
novena cuestión
así era
esta ha sido de regalo
no me ha pasado
así era
nuestro buen amigo
se vienen dos míticos para finalizar
las últimas preguntas son los míticos
así era
elegid una combinación histórica
de lanzador y rematador
que os pediríais para el balón parado
de vuestros equipos
puede ser un combo de liga
y otro de champions
yo lo tengo muy claro
estoy muy enamorado
muy muy muy
de De Llan Rice Gabriel Mavalláes
es el mejor del momento
Gabriel entra como un avión
y De Llan las pone muy fuerte
son super difíciles de defender
de hecho lo hablamos con Sergio Alegre
y él decía
tienes a un tipo
que te entra a rematar como Gabriel
tienes a otro que te entra como De Llan
y te entra como Gabriel
es que ya puedes practicar ahí
la defensa del balón parado
pero sí que es verdad
que a nivel histórico de España
hombre a ver
a mi la primera que se me ocurrió
igual es pecar
de que es aquí en España
pero yo sé que el gol más famoso
lo centra Modric
pero para mi la combinación
Kroos Ramos
ostras
la de Xavi Puyol
combinó mucho con Barça
no me suena tanto con Barça como con España
hay goles pero no tengo tanto
Piqué era mucho más goleador
de hecho hay uno de esos datos bonitos
lo verdad que no sé
cuál era o en qué competición
era que Piqué había marcado más goles que Ramos
Piqué marca una gola
Piqué no era solo de cabeza
no, no
igual era Champions
era un dato de estos
de quiz que crees que seguro
es una respuesta y es otra
de los que molan para plantearte cosas
pero el Kroos Modric
perdón el Kroos Ramos
a mi me parece top
de hecho Kroos
se ha hinchado en los últimos años
ponen asistencia
a balón parado
como pregunta en la histórica
que habla de la sierra
aquí en España
el Gaby Godin
como que Gaby es coque
Gaby pone
el corner del Camp Nou por ejemplo
si, es que aceptaba los dos
mucho
a mi me gustaba más coque
carremate a Godin
que es lo importante
de hecho de esa temporada
fue muy bonito también el Gastón Ramírez Godin
es que el segundo
era Miranda
Miranda es el que tiene el gol en la final de copa
Miranda entraba como un animal
esa temporada marca también mucho
creo
que el lanzador de los corners era Parejo
Otamendi
muy buena
de hecho
estoy viendo aquí
Piatti
con Otamendi
esa temporada marca mucho los dos
marca 6 Otamendi
y a Mustafi le recuerdo unos cuantos goles de cabeza
con Valencia
histórica de liga se me ha ocurrido que nosotros la valorábamos mucho
el Moneá en Inigo Martínez
si señor
quedaba mucho
Athletic siempre está muy arriba aquí
pero complicado
es complicado
es preguntita para que los pizarritos nos dejen
en comentarios
su combinación favorita
entraría aquí el Rory De La
es balón parado
elegí una combinación histórica
de lanzador y rematador
no hemos tenido el lanzamiento
estoy viendo aquí
temporada 2009
perdón 2008-2009
es la temporada que más asistencia está
Chaby en el Barça
y le daba a Márquez
en corner
Márquez tenía un gran golpe
balón parado
el primer gol
que vi en mi vida en el Camp Nou
fue de Márquez
Chaby
no hacía bien
el golpe de balón
pero centraba muy bien
menos tenso que otros
de lo que hablábamos de Julián
me gusta mucho como centra Rafa
el balón parado
es otro que le mete una hostia
estoy intentando encontrar
lanzadores de corner
Valencia y no que era Piatti
pero es que esta temporada
a Otamendi le asisten
Parejo, Rodrigo de Pol
Piatti y Gallà
me falta
Xofe Gulli
a mí me da la risa
también ha habido históricos lanzadores
de corner que no llegaban
centrando
el amigo Simo Sabrosa
sacaba los corners al primerísimo palo
creo que es
la acción
que más me podría hacer insultar a un jugador
en un terreno de juego
poner un corner de mierda en el minuto 88
cuando eres
ese central que sube
o sacas en corto mal
o directamente
es que no pasa el primer paro
y los que se lo piden
pero los que se lo piden
no me hagas oír
última cuestión
de Lops Twitter
si tuvieses que quedaros
ya que estamos en día de convocatoria
a selección española
si tuvieses que quedaros con un jugador
de cada equipo recién ascendido para que vaya
a la selección española
¿qué tres elegiríais?
haced una balanza entre nivel
y posible encaje
elegir un portero
escandale
vale
carles duarte
hay que nacionalizarlo
mañana sale un vídeo
o el domingo
carles duarte
el primero que se me ha ocurrido
en el che
como el centro del campo
está muy complicado
no te voy a nombrar a febas
ni a rodri mendoza
que es un poco trampa
alvaro nuñez
yo si que te lo podría meter
bueno
alvarito va a acabar jugando la selección
es que a parte
mola recuperar el perfil de lateral
con cuerpo de lateral
lateral y haza
y con nombre de lateral
lateral de verdad
a mi el primero que se me viene es carlos alvarez
si
yo había pensado
en ivan romero
en cuanto a movimientos podría encajar
delantero ratonero
puede envejecer muy mal esto
ivan romero selección
pues no jodere je
cual vas a decir
tu porque igual nos estamos dejando
al delantero
de 27 goles
no lo estoy diciendo
fede viñas
no podéis
no van a jugar
fede viñas
no me lo caigo
volvemos a no escucharte alex
mira si puedes apagar el micro
te perdemos
de lo viedo
no nombreses santi cazorla
porque tu lo digas
es que claro
porque ya ha ido
a mi me encantaria
me encantaria es imposible
es imposible
pero me encantaria alberto reina
es que es un jugador que me gusta mucho
pero es imposible
colombato no se le puede nacionalizar a colombato
que dejéis de fichar coño
yo creo que el mas cerca está realmente es escandal
siendo muy complicado
realmente
voy a añadir uno
antes que hablábamos
del perfil
de extremo que busca la selección
hombre ilias
en sub 22 comas ruegos pero es español
si si si
ilias mola
irías ilías
no se me preguntaria
la federacion
y si vas la ilias o no
hombre
la convocatoria la que va a ser
la iliada no
claro si marca gol habla jodimos
seria la iliada
miguel cállate que no ilías
audiseas claro
lo he vendido mal
de elches eso se ocurre otro
pues hombre rafael está muy entonado
es complicado
si se pudiera fichar adituro
y aquí peña puedes decir
a fengruber no ha debutado con la absoluta austriaca
a ver
es que realmente
tiene que ser febas
tiene que ser febas que
si no
alvaro rodriguez
ha debutado con la absoluta austriaca
es que es el que tiene
que ser febas
jodimos rodriguez
ha debutado con oruguay absoluta
yo creo que no
para segundas partes
perfil jose lu
pero no mares tampoco
y el che más allá de carlos alvarez
levanten
eso
morales ya no
no fue nunca
convocado
campaña
fue el que fue del levante
que era el primer
jugador en bastante tiempo
en ir de parte del levante
manu sanchez
está bien
realmente
el que más potencial
para llegar a la absoluta tiene
es pablo cuñat
pero claro que está siendo suplente
porque era la sub 21
esa es buena
mejor romero
no sé
es difícil
pero bueno
estando carlitos
claro
tu juntas a carlos alvarez
un alvaro noñez barra febas
escandel
es muy difícil que vaya ninguno
el que más cerca está es carlos alvarez
yo creo
es una partida en el fútbol manager
en la que no podía llevar
a jugadores de equipos grandes
define equipo grande
si le hice una definición
muy clara que es que jugara
en la competición europea
entonces claro
sevilla no es un grande
valencia tampoco
vale
no por ejemplo
era que jugara en champions
alex digues que se te ha roto el micro
no te quieren escuchar
alex date cuenta
son malas influencias
esa selección
alex yo la planteaba
para cuando se hablaba
de la invitación a la copa america
si
vas con esa selección b
que sería la leche
super divertida
ver a jugadores
creo que le
pensaba que le había pasado la foto a frank
que siempre nos pasaba una foto
pero no la tengo
era muy gracioso porque era delantero
delantero
de la boja inglesia
si te haces una partida
con el levante
a frank y el lo que le estás pasando
es una foto coya
ojo ojo
digues
suficiente
cerramos aquí